so herzlich willkommen meine sehr
geehrten damen und herren zur heutigen
pressekonferenz zum bericht der task
force eurofighter und zu den rechtlichen
und politischen konsequenzen daraus
neben dem herrn bundesminister stelle
ich die experten vor die heute auch
teilnehmen an der pressekonferenz das
ist generalmajor hans amberger der
leiter der internen revision und der
leiter der task force eurofighter und
wolfgang peschorn präsident der
finanzprokuratur dass solcher der anwalt
der republik darf den bundesministern
sein statement bieten er sehr geehrte
damen und herren herr präsident her
generalmajor ich habe bereits im vorfeld
den herrn bundeskanzler und herrn
vizekanzler
darüber informiert dass wir von der im
jahr 2012 im verteidigungsressort
eingerichteten task force ein bericht
über ihre tätigkeit bis jetzt vorgelegt
wurde
ich habe den bundeskanzler und auch den
vize-kanzler darüber informiert welche
konsequenzen wirklich schlüsse aus
diesem bericht zu die zu ziehen sind und
ich möchte gleich vorab am beginn dieser
pressekonferenz die wesentlichen die
zentralen punkte
dieses berichtes nennen zum einen führt
der bericht ganz klar und deutlich aus
das liegen klare beweise vor dass airbus
defence and space gmbh vormals rds und
zum zweiten die order freitag
jagdflugzeug gmbh trotz besseren wissens
die republik österreich wissentlich
getäuscht vorsätzlich getäuscht hat
durch diese täuschungshandlung ist der
republik österreich ein enormer
finanzieller schaden erwachsen experten
in unserem haus beziffern diesen schaden
mit bis zu 1 1 milliarden euro
ich möchte zu diesem zeitpunkt noch
grundsätzlich sagen und es ist mir ein
ganz wesentliches auch wesentliches
persönliches anliegen das nicht
akzeptiert werden kann und das wird
nicht akzeptieren
dass die steuerzahler über einen
kaufpreis auch schmiergelder
mitfinanzieren
es ist ein enormer wie dargestellt
finanzieller schaden entstanden es ist
auch ein schaden entstanden der da der
geeignet ist durch solche
rechtsgeschäfte durch dieses
rechtsgeschäft auch einen
vertrauensverlust in das österreichische
bundesheer stattfinden zu lassen
wir sehen seit einiger zeit dass das
österreichische bundesheer einer
situation ist durch diese investitionen
beim österreichischen bundesheer dass
die bevölkerung dies auch als
investition in die sicherheit
österreichs mitträgt auch akzeptiert wir
werden beispielsweise in den nächsten
jahren bis 2020 17 milliarden euro in
das österreichische bundesheer in
ausrüstung in personal in infrastruktur
investiert investieren und jeder
verdacht derzeit zu geeignet ist hier
dieses vertrauensverhältnis sind das
österreichische bundesheer zu gefährden
jeder verdacht der möglicherweise auch
dazu beiträgt dass die notwendige
modernisierung des österreichischen
bundesheer gefährdet ist
der als auszuräumen der scan deutlich
auszuräumen
es ist deshalb meine pflicht und das ist
auch meine überzeugung dass wir alles
dazu beitragen müssen dass wir alle
zweifel dass rechtsgeschäfte das
beschaffungsvorgänge beim
österreichischen bundesheer
rechtskonform ablaufen rechtskonform
durchgeführt werden dass wir all diese
zweifel beseitigen
und deshalb haben wir uns aufgrund
dieses berichtes und aufgrund der
ergebnisse dieses berichtes auch dazu
entschlossen dass wir bei der
staatsanwaltschaft wien eine
strafanzeige einbringen diese
strafanzeige wurde mit heutigem tag
eingebracht
und gleichzeitig haben wir auch und habe
ich auch dem präsidenten der
finanzprokuratur beauftragt diesen
entstandenen schaden durch dieses
rechtsgeschäft entstandenen schaden im
rahmen eines privat beteiligten
anschlusses sicherzustellen und in
weiterer folge auch geltend zu machen um
auch eine sicherzustellen dass hier
jegliche verjährungs themen
und verjährungsfristen ausgeschlossen
sind die wichtigsten erkenntnisse dieser
task force des erhebungsbögen minuten
der leiter der taskforce generalmajor
hans amberger und auch der präsident der
finanzprokuratur wolfgang peschorn im
detail erläutern
ich möchte hier dieser stelle auch die
gelegenheit wahrnehmen dass ich mich bei
der taskforce grundsätzlich bedanke für
ihre arbeit
es war eine externe und interne
mitarbeiter in dieser gruppe eingebunden
und ich glaube sie um wesentlich dazu
beigetragen dass es gelungen ist und
gelingt diese causa eurofighter die er
schon jahrelang thema in
sicherheitspolitischen innenpolitischen
fragestellungen ist auch aufzuklären
und dass es auch gelingt in diesem
zusammenhang die ansprüche der republik
in weiterer folge auch die ansprüche der
steuerzahler entsprechend auch
einzubringen
meine sehr geehrten damen und herren die
sicherung des österreichischen
luftraumes durch unsere luftstreitkräfte
durch wirklich hervorragend ausgebildete
piloten durch ausgebildete techniker ist
in keinster weise durch diese
vorgehensweise gefährdet ist nicht
gefährdet
aufgrund dessen dass wir jetzt
strafrechtlich in vorlage treten dass
wir uns als privatbeteiligter in diesen
verfahren einsetzen die luftstreitkräfte
werden auch weiterhin volle dispositions
fähigkeit über den eurofighter haben die
piloten werden auch weiterhin mit dem
order weiter fliegen das heißt das
bedeutet und das ist mir besonders
wichtig einerseits die
luftraumüberwachung ist weiterhin
sichergestellt
und ich glaube in diesem zusammenhang
muss müssen wir muss man auch sagen und
müssen wir auch klar festlegen dass auch
die standorte zur luftraumüberwachung
nachhaltig gesichert sind
die tatsache und ich glaube das ist auch
ganz wichtig die tatsache dass wir heute
unseren eurofighter lieferanten bei der
staatsanwaltschaft wien anzeige die
tatsache dass wir
einen privatbeteiligten anschluss auch
machen ist nicht und führt nicht dazu
dass wir die systematik der
luftraumüberwachung der aktiven
luftraumüberwachung hinterfragen
ich bin fest davon überzeugt und stehe
auch hundertprozentig dahinter dass wir
auch hinkünftig aktive
luftraumüberwachung mit abfangjägern in
österreich für die souveränität unseres
luftraumes auch in weiterer folge
betreiben müssen
an dieser stelle möchte ich meine
ausführungen unterbrechen und würde
jetzt bitten herrn generalmajor hans
hamberger über die tätigkeiten der task
force über die zusammensetzung der task
force über die abläufe in der task force
zu referieren und im anschluss würde ich
versuchen den herrn präsidenten wolfgang
peschorn
über die genauen inhaltlichen
ausführungen zur strafanzeige aber auch
zum privatbeteiligten anschluss auskunft
zu geben bitteschön den rang der
bundesminister guten morgen meine damen
und herren
die taskforce legt heute ihren bericht
vor wir zeigen damit die eigenen
untersuchungen
wir bringen die wesentlichen
untersuchungsergebnisse vor und wir
haben in der in der untersuchung und in
der dokumentation auch empfehlungen
ausgesprochen
die wir kurz ansprechen werden lassen
sie mich zunächst einmal erklären wann
diese task force zu arbeiten begonnen
hatte es gab einen bestimmten anlass
fall im jahre 2011 kam es in italien zu
einer verhaftung eines gewissen
gianfranco lande und bei den
einvernahmen durch die dortigen justiz
ermittlungsbehörden hat diese person auf
ein netzwerk verwiesen an beratern und
lobbyisten das heute unter dem namen
vector netzwerk bekannt ist
es kam in der folge
zur aufnahme strafrechtliche
untersuchungen durch die
staatsanwaltschaft rom dann münchen und
auch in wien und kurz danach ende 2012
hat der damalige bundesminister für
landesverteidigung mich beauftragt eine
taskforce einzusetzen
was war der auftrag an diese task force
ich war beauftragt im wirkungsbereich
des bundesministeriums für
landesverteidigung und sport die
beschaffung die damalige beschaffung des
abfangjägers eurofighter umfassend zu
untersuchen
mir wurde mit gegeben sofern wir
rechtsverletzungen zu lasten der
republik österreich feststehen können
diese aufzubereiten all fliegt daraus
abzuleitende ansprüche festzumachen und
den weg des zivil- oder strafrechtlichen
verfahrens zu suchen für den fall dass
die untersuchungen auch entsprechende
ergebnisse zeigen die task force setzt
sich zusammen aus experten unseres
hauses unter meiner leitung die
finanzprokuratur insbesonders der
präsident wolfgang peschorn hat uns von
beginn an umfassend unterstützt
wir hatten eine umfassende rechtliche
expertise auf die wir uns stützen
konnten
wir haben im frühjahr 2016 also vor
einem etwa dreiviertel jahr weitere
experten hinzu genommen
es war die phase der intensivierung der
aufarbeitung der sache eurofighter und
wenigen externen experten herangezogen
haben
dabei handelt es sich um grant thornton
ohne treue advisory als forensik
experten
wir haben hinzugezogen
hellsberg kastner & partner
rechtsanwälte als experten des
österreichischen strafrecht und auch des
deutschen strafrechts
wir haben weiters hinzugezogen
skadden arps slate und mega
rechtsanwälte als experten für
korruptions recht in den vereinigten
staaten und im vereinigten königreich
von großbritannien und wir stützen uns
auch ab auf zivilrechtliche
wissenschaftliche expertise in dieser
komplexen causa wir zogen heran
die universitätsprofessoren christian
rabl und andreas kitschke was hat die
taskforce nun gemacht
wie schon erwähnt nach umfänglichen
umfangreichen untersuchungen gab es im
frühjahr 2016 eine intensivierung phase
auf der suche nach weiteren relevanten
beweismitteln
wir haben hier so ein projekt unter der
bezeichnung linear geschaffen und dort
die untersuchungen durchgeführt
der auftrag war bis ende vergangenen
jahres verwertbare
untersuchungsergebnisse zu den vorgängen
vorzulegen die die beschaffung und den
kern ankauf der eurofighter und damit im
zusammenhang stehen
zugleich sollte eine sachliche grundlage
geschaffen werden um die entscheidung
der republik österreich zu ermöglichen
über die weitere vorgehensweise welche
wesentlichen quellen standen uns zur
verfügung
wir haben im wege der finanzprokuratur
laufend an einsicht in den akt
der staatsanwaltschaft liegen genommen
wir haben alle intern vorhandenen
dokumente zu diesem vorgang erfasst und
aufbereitet und wir haben auch
dokumentation erhalten vom ehemaligen
vorsitzenden des parlamentarischen
untersuchungsausschusses zum thema
eurofighter vom abgeordneten zum
nationalrat dr peter pilz der uns diese
dokumentation zugeleitet hat
zuletzt war es ein ergebnis eigener
recherchen in verknüpfung mit diesen
anderen quellen die ich genannt habe
die zu den entsprechenden ergebnissen
geführt haben
die heute vorliegen was ist das die
untersuchungen taskforce eurofighter
belegen konkrete anhaltspunkte für straf
und zivilrechtlich relevante
täuschungshandlungen von
verantwortlichen entscheidungsträgern
und organen die den zwei airbus
unternehmen nämlich airbus defence and
space gmbh vormals aufgetreten als erde
ist deutschland gmbh und eurofighter
jagdflugzeuge gmbh zugerechnet werden
können
sie haben andererseits hervorgebracht
dass diese arglistige täuschung 'nen die
republik österreich massiv geschädigt
haben
die untersuchungen der taskforce
eurofighter haben zudem eindeutige
hinweise dafür hervorgebracht dass die
vereinbarung und abwicklung des
sogenannten gegengeschäfte insbesonders
die von den beiden airbus unternehmen zu
verantwortende zwischenschaltung des
vector netzwerks eine grundlage sowie
quelle für unredliches verhalten zu
lasten der republik österreich waren
vector netzwerk ist nach den
untersuchungsergebnissen jedenfalls von
airbus der betrag von über 100 millionen
euro geflossen
und dieser betrag wurde der republik
österreich für die beschaffung und den
ankauf der eurofighter verborgen in
rechnung gestellt darüber hinaus belegen
unsere untersuchungen dass wesentliche
inhalte von beschaffungsvorgängen von
rüstungsmaterial ohne zutun der republik
österreich über einige wenige personen
die als berater und bevollmächtigte der
anbieter des rüstungs materials
auftraten
initiiert und abgewickelt wurden
schließlich haben wir auch über den
angloamerikanischen rechtsraum
hineingeschaut aus sicht der compliance
vorschriften dieses angebot des
amerikanischen rechts bestehen weiterhin
anhaltspunkte dafür dass wegen der
zahlreichen gegen geschäfte mit us
amerikanischen gegenparteien und deren
abwicklung durch die einschaltung des
vector netzwerks die zuständigkeit
englischer und oder us amerikanischer
behörden begründet worden sein könnte
die diesbezüglichen untersuchungen sind
noch nicht abgeschlossen
es ist aber nicht ausgeschlossen dass
nach abschluss der untersuchungen
ebenfalls eine eingabe bei den
englischen oder us-amerikanischen
behörden in erwägung gezogen wird
wie geht es nun weiter mit der task
force
wir haben den bericht vorgelegt
wir haben strafanzeige eingebracht
wir erheben unsere
schadenersatzforderungen und gerade
durch die einbringung dieser
dokumentation unterstützen wir die
strafermittlungsbehörden in deren arbeit
zur aufarbeitung der causa eurofighter
und damit gebe ich weiter an
dr wolfgang wie schon danke gott meine
damen und herren
die republik österreich hat heute eine
strafanzeige eingebracht sie substanz
irrt sie ist ca 130 seiten stark und
enthält 97 beilagen die neue sind für
die staatsanwaltschaft und wir haben
hier keine wiederholungen in der
strafanzeige angeführt sondern es sind
neue sachverhalte die wird der
staatsanwaltschaft wien zur kenntnis
bringen und beantragt haben
diesem sachverhalt nachzugehen sie haben
gehört die republik österreich wurde im
jahr 2002 beginnend über den abschluss
des kaufvertrages im jahr 2003 bis in
die zukunft des jahres 27 getäuscht ohne
diese täuschung hätte die republik
österreich
diese kaufverträge nicht abgeschlossen
und auch nicht den vergleich in der form
des jahres 2007 geschlossen
was sind die konkreten vorwürfe die in
der strafanzeige angeführt werden
es sind zwei sachverhalte die bei näher
und intensiver prüfung sich für die task
force als stichhaltig herausgestellt
haben zum einen ist es der vorwurf dass
die eurofighter jagdflugzeug gmbh und
airbus verpflichtet gewesen wäre
explizit gegen geschäftskosten in der
angebots bekanntgabe aus zu preisen
dies ist nicht erfolgt tatsächlich
der kaufpreis der letztendlich in raten
von der republik österreich bezahlt
wurde
einen betrag von 183 4 millionen euro
enthalten
der von eurofighter jagdflugzeug gmbh
und airbus verwendet wurde um kosten im
weitesten sinn für gegengeschäfte
abzudecken
wir wissen heute dass ein erheblicher
teil dieses betrages der von der
republik österreich entrichtet werden
musste weil sie davon nicht in kenntnis
gesetzt worden war dass es sich hier um
gegen geschäftskosten handelt das mehr
oder minder dubiose und kriminelle
sektor netzwerk geflossen ist hätte uns
die eurofighter jagdflugzeug gmbh
diesen umstand bekannt gegeben
dann hätten wir den kaufvertrag als
republik österreich nicht abgeschlossen
aber was hat die eurofighter
jagdflugzeug gmbh und airbus mit diesem
vorgang bewirkt sie hat die damaligen
machthaber der republik österreich über
den wahren wert des fluggerätes
getäuscht weil sie unter 83,4 millionen
jedenfalls einen preis begehrt hat der
diesem gerät nicht angemessen war
zweitens im kaufvertrag wurde explizit
vereinbart ein fluggerät der bauart
tranche 2 block 8
ausnahmsweise war es zulässig die ersten
fluggeräte in einer noch älteren version
nämlich in der bauart block 1 1 block 5
zu liefern
allerdings hat der die eurofighter
jagdflugzeug gmbh die verpflichtung
vertraglich übernommen
dieses fluggerät auf einem bauzustand
dass der tranche 2 block 8 aufzurüsten
unsere untersuchungen haben ergeben dass
tatsächlich unser vertragspartner
nie in der lage gewesen war oder wäre
dieses fluggerät uns zu den vereinbarten
lieferzeit punkten zur verfügung zu
stellen und zu liefern und darüber
hinaus weiß gänzlich unwirtschaftlich
die versprochene aufrüstung von fliegern
der tranche 1 block 5 auf die höhere
bauart vorzunehmen weil sie
unwirtschaftlich und mit enormen kosten
für unsere vertragspartner verbunden
gewesen wäre
wir wurden daher nicht nur als republik
österreich getäuscht darüber dass die
lieferfähigkeit zu den vereinbarten
zeitpunkt nicht gegeben war
man kann auch schlicht und ergreifend
sagen unser vertragspartner hatte
offensichtlich nie die absicht den
vereinbarten liefert gegenstand in der
vereinbarten oder bedingungen art zu
liefern
ich glaube es ist verständlich wenn man
daraus nur einen schluss ziehen kann
dass die republik österreich damals und
im jahr 2007 nie jene vereinbarungen und
vor allem den kaufvertrag unter fährt
und abgeschlossen hätte hätte sie von
diesen umständen gewusst sie mussten
daher der republik österreich bis heute
verborgen bleiben weil sie diese
konsequenzen zur folge gehabt hätten nun
wie errechnet sich oder wie begründet
sich der schaden noch mal republik
österreich hätte wären die
täuschungshandlungen nicht gesetzt
worden
diesen kaufvertrag nicht abgeschlossen
deswegen hat sie im umfang der nun
aufgrund des verkehrs aus 2007 bestellt
und gelieferten 15 eurofighter einen
anspruch auf rückerstattung des
kaufpreises
dem muss sie sich abziehen lassen den
zeit- beziehungsweise den restwert
dieser fluggeräte hinzu kommt zu diesem
betrag der sich hier errechnet die
aufwendungen die die republik österreich
für den betrieb dieses fluggerätes
eurofighter getätigt hat abzüglich der
hypothetischen aufwendungen für ein
alternatives fluggerät weil er in der
zwischenzeit bis zum 31 12 2016 auch
einen luftraumüberwachung stattgefunden
hat hieraus errechnet sich ein betrag
von 1 1 milliarden derzeit und in diesem
betrag ist der von mir genannte
teilbetrag von 183,4 millionen der ich
darf daran erinnern
verwendet wurde letztendlich um gegen
geschäftskosten im weitesten sinn zu
finanzieren und die überwiegenden teil
in der so genannte netzwerk von vector
geschleust wurde
enthalten wenn sie wollen haben wir und
das ist der punkt einmal jedenfalls ein
anspruch auf zahlung von 183 4 millionen
und dieser schaden berechnet sich mit 1
1 milliarden
die 1,1 milliarden sind noch von
offizieren und bis dato weil es ein
einzigartiger fall ist in der
rechtswissenschaft noch nicht endgültig
diskutierten juristischen fragen
abhängig
wir sehen aber gute gründe dass
letztendlich uns gerichte in einer
auseinandersetzung einen betrag von 1,1
milliarden als schaden der bereits jetzt
bis 31 12 2016 der republik österreich
entstanden ist zu sprechen werden und
eines
es wird auch zukünftig auch heute noch
ein schaden entstehen weil wir weitere
aufwendungen haben aus dem betrieb des
teuren eurofighters und auch diesen
haben wir geltend gemacht und zwar in
form eines feststellung begehrens
abschließend was heute geschehen ist um
8 29 im elektronischen weg die
finanzprokuratur hat im auftrag des
bundesministeriums für
landesverteidigung und sport
die strafanzeige eingebracht und sich
gleichzeitig namens der republik
österreich und für die steuerzahlerinnen
und steuerzahler mit dem schaden der der
republik österreich durch das
fortgesetzte betrügerische und
arglistige handeln unseres
vertragspartners entstanden ist
vollständig angeschlossen
danke danke herr präsident danke herr
generalmajor wie sie diesen beiden
ausführungen entnehmen können haben wir
durch den durch das einbringen der
strafanzeige durch den anschluss als
privatbeteiligte unsere zivilrechtlichen
ansprüche gewahrt wir haben unsere
zivilrechtlichen ansprüche auch vor dem
faktor der verjährung geschützt und in
weiterer folge sind unsere
tatsachenfeststellungen unsere
erhebungsergebnisse der staatsanwalt zur
verfügung gestellt worden und die
staatsanwalt das ist aufgabe der
staatsanwalt das jetzt strafrechtlich zu
überprüfen ob in angriff zu nehmen
stellt sich aber auch in diesem
zusammenhang natürlich zwei weitere
fragen zum einen die frage wie geht es
weiter mit der luftraumüberwachung mit
der aktiven luftraumüberwachung in
österreich es ist glaube ich kein
geheimnis und es ist auch teilweise den
ausführungen zu entnehmen gewesen dass
die eurofighter der tranche 1 dem grunde
nach im betrieb extrem teuer sind für
das österreichische bundesheer extrem
teuer sind und das auch noch zusätzliche
kosten anfallen werden dass updates
kosten umstellungskosten etc betreffen
wir rechnen allein im jahr 2017 das für
den betrieb des eurofighters rund 80
millionen euro veranschlagt werden
essen und entsprechend auch eingepreist
sind die prognosen für das nächste jahr
sind eher in die richtung auszulegen
dass die kosten steigen werden
zudem müssen wir und das war auch
diskussionspunkt des letzten jahres
zudem müssen wir auch eine entscheidung
treffen
in bezug auf die saab 105 aus diesem
grunde und aus diesem zusammenhang
heraus haben wir die entscheidung
getroffen dass wir eine sonderkommission
einrichten
eine sonderkommission unter der leitung
des kommandanten der luftstreitkräfte
karl gruber brigadier karl gruber und es
wird seine aufgabe sein
bis zum 30 juni zu erheben und
festzulegen wie können wir die
luftraumüberwachung militärisch
effizient durchführen einerseits aber
und das ist auch gegenstand der
überprüfungen der arbeiten die hier zu
tätigen sind wie können wir
kostengünstig wie können wir
wirtschaftlich vertretbar
auch in diesem zusammenhang hin künftig
die luftraumüberwachung sicherstellen
der zweite aspekt und das geht auch aus
dem bericht taskforce hervor ist
natürlich jener dass der verdacht
besteht dass hier airbus verantwortliche
den plan verfolgten zu einem sehr frühen
zeitpunkt wenn ich schon von anfang an
das rechtsgeschäft ist diese 183
millionen euro dazu zu verwenden einen
berater einen interessenten netzwerk
über unzählige offshore konstruktionen
es wurde ja schon genannt die vector
konstruktion und das vector netzwerk zur
verfügung zu stellen
offensichtlich und das muss man auch
feststellen und festhalten sind gegen
geschäfte im militärischen bereich bei
rüstungsgeschäften beim militärischen
anschaffungen für einzelnen personen und
berater in diesem umfeld offensichtlich
sehr dazu geeignet sich zu bereichern
ich würde sogar meinen gegengeschäfte
sind offensichtlich eine ideale
trägerrakete für korruption
misswirtschaft und geldwäsche
wir aber haben nicht nicht sagen möchte
auch betonen dass nicht alle
gegengeschäfte davon betroffen sind
diese fakten sind aber dermaßen klar und
eindeutig so dass wir auch hier in
diesem punkt nicht zur tagesordnung
übergehen können so dass wir uns
entschlossen haben den herrn präsidenten
der finanzprokuratur zu beauftragen uns
verhaltensmaßnahmen zu geben
auszuarbeiten was wollen wir und wie
wollen wir hin künftig rüstungsgeschäfte
durchführen welche maßnahmen sind zu
setzen und ein punkt dieser maßnahmen
wird auch sein und das müssen wir auch
an diskutieren ob in zukunft es auch
noch zulässig sein soll
im rüstungsbereich gegengeschäfte
durchzuführen
die europäische union hat bereits für
den zivilen bereich und auch dass
bereits 2011 festgelegt dass
gegengeschäfte an für sich verboten sind
und sie hat es auch mit einer
einschränkung für rüstungsgeschäfte
ausgesagt sind insofern das
gegengeschäft im bereich von
rüstungsgeschäften nur zulässig sind
wenn es besondere sicherheitsgründe
dafür gibt ich werde auch hier für
gespräche suchen mit dem
wirtschaftsminister werde die gespräche
suchen mit der wirtschaftskammer werde
auch natürlich mit unseren experten im
haus diesbezüglich ein gespräch führen
aber wir werden auch gemeinsam mit den
ergebnissen der finanzprokuratur die mit
31 mai vorliegen sollen und die wir dann
auch bekanntgeben werden auch eine
entscheidung treffen wie es hinkünftig
in weiterer folge mit gegengeschäften
sein wird ich möchte betonen dass wir
alles machen werden dass wir alles
gemacht haben und dass wir auch in
zukunft alles machen werden dass alle
österreicher alle österreicherinnen
darauf vertrauen können dass sie sicher
sein können dass wir künftige
beschaffungen in unserem ressort
rüstungsgeschäfte in unserem ressort
sauber und korrekt ablaufen werden
meine sehr geehrten damen und herren mit
geht es in diesem zusammenhang um
doppelte sicherheit
sicherheit für die bevölkerung und
sicherheit vor korruption
danke für die aufmerksamkeit danke herr
bundesminister jetzt kommen wir zu den
fragen
soweit ich es nicht benennen bitte auch
namen name und medium sagen herr fritzl
bitte die presse bzw weniger unter
welchen umständen bedingen streckt ich
glaube wir haben jetzt die situation
gerade dargestellt wir sind den weg
gegangen dass wir eine strafanzeige
einbringen dass wir uns als
privatbeteiligte anschließen das sind
klar vorgezeichnete wege
auf der einen seite und wir müssen wir
die ergebnisse und die erhebungen der
gerichte abwarten wir werden unsere es
dazu beitragen und die gerichte
unterstützen
auf der anderen seite gibt es einen
klaren auftrag an die sonderkommission
unter der leitung des kommandanten der
luftstreitkräfte hier auch offen zu
denken neu zu denken
die vorgaben sind offen gehalten die
eine vorgabe
was die zukünftige art und weise der
luftraumüberwachung in österreich
betrifft ist jene dass wir sie effizient
mit wenig militärische effizient
gestalten wollen die zweite variante ist
und die zweite vorgabe ist dass wir sie
kostengünstiger wir zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt haben wollen
und in diesem kontext ist in beiden
facetten alles möglich herr seidel bitte
vom standard
österreich wollte ja dass zwei flugzeuge
haben
österreich hat damals einen besonderen
wunsch gehabt dass früher flugzeuge
geliefert als eigentlich planbar
waltraud zwar nicht lieferbar war
man hätte ja damals auch vereinbart
gehabt zumindest war das mein wissen
stand damals dass diese 31 flugzeuge
durch flugzeuge der trotz zwei
ausgetauscht werden dies auch darauf hat
die republik österreicher dann
verzichtet in dem vergleich und das
zweite ist wenn jetzt da der auftrag an
den er gegangen ist zu prüfen wie es mit
den mit den weiteren trainingsflugzeug
beziehung der luftraumüberwachung
weitergeht soweit ich weiß ist 105
nachfolge hätte er eigentlich schon vor
jahren entschieden werden sollen
dann wurde mal der termin november 20 16
genannt offenbar gibt es immer noch
keine entscheidung bzw nicht einmal ein
pflichtenheft für eine ausschreibung
würde die erste antwort dann gerne
weitergeben aber zum zweiten teil glaube
ich dass es in der situation was wir
letztes jahr aufgearbeitet haben
in der situation dass wir heute
präsentiert haben in der situation und
unter den vorgaben dass wir die gesamte
aktive luftraumüberwachung das betrifft
nicht nur die saab 105 und da sage ich
ganz klar unter diesen aspekten neu
überprüfen und mit einem offenen
ergebnis in diese überprüfung gehen und
am 30 juni die entscheidungen
bekanntgeben werden
und das betrifft die gesamte aktive
luftraumüberwachung zusammen 105 ist zu
sagen dass die saab 105 jedenfalls bis
2020 in betrieb ist und flugfähig sein
wird bitte ich glaube es findet wird
sich niemand hier im raum und außerhalb
dieses rahmens finden der
verhandlern des jahres 2007 unterstehen
wird das ihnen bekannt war dass im jahr
2003 der republik österreich ein
kaufgegenstand versprochen wurde der
letztendlich nicht in dieser qualität
und in dem lieferumfang auch geliefert
werden kann
wir gehen davon aus und dann dafür
beweise dass auch im jahr 2007
diese liefern unfähigkeit des jahres
2003 über die die republik österreich
getäuscht wurde uns vorenthalten wurde
und niemand hätte in diesem wissen
diesem vergleich 2007 in dieser form
abgeschlossen
mit anderen worten auf die
strafrechtliche täuschungshandlung und
den daraus resultierenden schaden der
republik im jahr 2007 von seiten der
republik österreich niemand verzichtet
danke herr präsident die austria
presseagentur bitte von pula jetzt zwei
fragen die erste an den minister
bezüglich des auftrags an die
sonderkommission inwiefern spielen da
oder können da internationale
kooperationen eine rolle spielen bei der
künftigen luftraumüberwachung und meine
zweite frage werden den hp schon haben
wir das richtig verstanden dass in den
privatbeteiligten anschluss nur die
summe der 183 4 millionen genannt wird
obwohl man von einkommen ein
milliardenschaden ausgeht wenn ja warum
ist das so können sie das noch mal
erklären sollte man da nicht hoch
angesetzt
zur ersten frage kann ich das eigentlich
nur wiederholen was ich bereits
beantwortet habe wir haben diese
sonderkommission eingerichtet um
vollkommen ergebnisoffen
die luftraumüberwachung die aktive
luftraumüberwachung neu zu beurteilen
militärische effizient und
wirtschaftlich zu beurteilen und in
diesem sinne
und weil es ergebnisoffen ist sind alle
varianten denkbar
wir machen mit den privatbeteiligten
anschluss den gesamten schaden geltend
nicht nur der 1,1 milliarden sondern
auch den zukünftig noch entstehenden
schaden
das wird nur aus juristisch technischen
dingen explizit passiert ist dass wir
uns zunächst mit einem betrag von 183 4
millionen explizit anschließen
in den privatbeteiligten anschluss sind
alle überlegungen die ich ihnen
dargestellt habe wenn noch ein bisschen
unverständlich für normalsterbliche
sondern im juristendeutsch
ausgeschildert und daher auch dieser
betrag von 1 1 milliarden genannt
das gold christian reif für servus tv
folgende frage welche personen stehen
hinter diesen weg der netzwerk das ist
eine bezeichnung dafür wie es genannt
man ist wie kann man sich das vorstellen
die folge frage wer hat von diesen 183 4
millionen euro profitiert wo ist das
geld in siam erwähnt offshore konstrukte
was bedeutet dass wo liegt das geld
wir haben das habe ich aus geführt
festgestellt dass geld in ein netzwerk
geflossen ist und dort über eine kaskade
an verschiedenen offshore gesellschaften
verteilt wurde
das ist gegenstand aktuell der
strafrechtlichen untersuchungen sowohl
in österreich als auch in deutschland in
münchen
alles was wir dazu finden und seen
zeigen wir der staatsanwaltschaft teilen
das mit da es aber bereits untersucht
wird ist es nicht gegenstand unserer
ermittlungen jörg hofer von der zeit im
bild bitte auch noch an den herrn
hamberger sie haben erwähnt dass sie
auch eigene untersuchungen angestellt
haben
die namen sind hinlänglich bekannt die
mit vector in zusammenhang stehen
sind ihnen neue namen bekannt sind neun
personen aufgetaucht vor allem aus dem
österreichischen politischen bereich die
vorher noch nicht genannt worden uns
sind bei unseren untersuchungen keine
neuen namen bekannt geworden die über
das hinausgehen was bei den
staatsanwaltschaften bereits untersucht
wird
im zusammenhang mit dem vorwurf den wir
jetzt angezeigt haben also die beiden
betrugs tatbestände sind natürlich nicht
nur die beiden unternehmen genannt die
ja nach dem
verbandsverantwortlichkeitsgesetz
angezeigt worden sondern es werden
natürlich auch die manager die
ehemaligen damaligen manager die
machthaber dieser unternehmen waren mit
angezeigt hinter dem herrnhofer
hat jemand aufgezeigt bitte bitte kurz
nach mittag wieder sieben vom
handelsblatt eine frage an heimlichen
posco fiel
die republik österreich hat die eine
bereitschaft befindet eine bereitschaft
für einen vergleich mit den beiden
firmen airbus und eurofighter oder
schließen sie das aus und begeben sich
auf die lange reise der gerichte bis zu
einer endgültigen entscheidung über die
schadensumme herzlichen dank also wir
haben jetzt mit der mit dem einbringen
der strafanzeige und natürlich auch mit
den anschluss als privatbeteiligte einen
klaren weg vorgezeichnet
ich glaube das sehen insbesondere im
bereich der strafanzeige dieser weg
automatisch beschritten werden muss aber
es ist mir auch klar und dazu stehe ich
auch zur verfügung das auch das ressort
auch die republik die vertreter wenn es
einen gesprächswunsch seitens der bosch
gruppe gibt auch diesen wunsch
entsprechen wird
bitte hier die nächste frage camera link
ard als deutsches fernsehen eine frage
herr minister
warum kommt die reaktion erst jetzt
warum nicht zu einem früheren zeitpunkt
ich glaube jetzt hat jahrelang über
dieses rüstungsgeschäft über diesen
eurofighter deal sicherheitspolitische
diskussionen politische diskussionen
gegeben
es gab einen untersuchungsausschuss es
gab die staatsanwalt in den beginn der
staatsanwaltschaftlichen ermittlungen
2011 es gab die beiden das haus gruppen
in unserem haus im
wirtschaftsministerium beginnen mit 2012
und wir haben jetzt eine situation
vorgefunden im letzten jahr dass wir
wirklich umfangreich unterlagen zusammen
führen konnten das war eine neue
situation daher auch dieser vorstoß und
wir zeigen ja an und für sich nur dinge
an die neu sind einerseits und
andererseits bin ich auch nicht dafür zu
haben dass man auch wenn es eine
populäre angelegenheit ist dass man
schnellschüsse macht sondern dass wir
wie wir es auch dargelegt haben durch
die zusammensetzung der taskforce dass
wir seriös aufbereiten und dann wenn wir
glauben und davon sind überzeugt dass
wir die entsprechenden beweismittel
vorlegen können dann auch in die
offensive gehen und die haben wir heute
diese schritte gemacht
hinter christian geinitz von der
frankfurter allgemeinen zeitung ich habe
zwei fragen sie gestatten die erste ist
eine technische warum ist überhaupt
airbus wird airbus beklagt oder
angezeigt zum vertragsabschluss war
durch eurofighter vertragspartner
mittlerweile des airbus war der
mehrheitseigentümer aber eigentlich
müssen sie doch nur gegen eurofighter
vorgehen also eher technische frage und
die zweite geht um die gegengeschäfte es
gibt ja auch diese offset verpflichtung
innerhalb der republik also ich glaube
die quote bei ihnen beträgt über 200%
gegengeschäfte die also an
österreichische firmen gegangen sind von
vier milliarden euro
wenn es jetzt zu einer lösung kommt wer
die dann auch rückabgewickelt das heißt
wird das geld fließt das dann auch
wieder zurückfinden zu ihrer ersten
frage tatsächlich wenn sie wenn sie hier
den hintergrund anschauen
die damals die vertragsverhandlungen
auch die abwicklung des abgeschlossenen
vertrages stattgefunden hat ist eine
ganz starke verquickung in tatsächlicher
hinsicht zwischen eurofighter
jagdflugzeug gmbh und damals erde es nun
umbenannt airbus zu beobachten
daher ist eine faktische
geschäftsführung im weitesten sinn durch
airbus gegeben gewesen und aus unserer
sicht beide unternehmen für die heute
zur anzeige gebrachten
täuschungshandlungen verantwortlich ja
und zu ihrer zweiten frage die
gegengeschäfte betreffend möchte ich
anführen
die republik österreich hat
gegengeschäfte gewollt es ist dazu ein
eigener vertrag über die abwicklung von
gegen geschäfte zustande gekommen
dieser vertrag resultiert in dem bereich
des wirtschaftsministeriums das wird von
dort von der staatsanwaltschaft von der
dortigen task-force untersucht die
teilen ihre ergebnisse dem staatsanwalt
mit der führt auch ermittlungen im
bereich der gegengeschäfte generell was
aber jetzt die rückabwicklung betrifft
die sie hier in den raum gestellt haben
hier ist der vertrag über die
gegengeschäfte sehr klar nämlich es gibt
keine rückabwicklung jene gegengeschäfte
die erbracht wurden wurden vertragsgemäß
erbracht
die überwiegende masse dagegen geschäfte
die als redlich beurteilt werden wird da
gibt es überhaupt nichts anzumerken dazu
von unserer seite das
verteidigungsministerium
ja und es droht auch keine
rückabwicklung frau weißensteiner hat
sich das mikrofon geschnappt wie vom
standard können sie uns schon eine
einschätzung geben wie viel die
taskforce ungefähr bisher gekostet hat
mit beiziehung dieser internationalen
experten und den vereinigten staaten und
so weiter und dann noch eine zweite
bitte herr p schon sie haben gesagt dass
man 2007 das nicht abgeschlossen hätte
diesen kauf diese update probleme mit
dem branchen waren aber sehr wohl schon
thema im untersuchungsausschuss damals
der ball erlief frage kann eine
politische verantwortung des trotzdem
abgeschlossen wurden ist aus heutiger
sicht schon ausgeschlossen werden
damals war verteidigungsminister
vielleicht zur ersten frage ich glaube
es ist selbstverständlich dass man sich
in einer so einer komplexen thematik
darf nur daran erinnern dass uns fünf
terabyte an material zur verfügung
gestanden ist dass wir dass wir uns in
einer derartigen komplexen materie
natürlich auch externe experten bedienen
davon verständnis bitten dass wir die
zahlen die kosten dieser experten heute
nicht nennen werden sie bewegen sich
aber in den normalen rahmen für
honorarnoten und ich wäre und bin
natürlich bereit dazu auch die
abschließenden kosten dann dem
rechnungshof den verteidigungsausschuss
auch entsprechend offen zu legen
die zweite frage zu ihrer frage im jahr
2007 für politische verantwortung
aber ich keine verantwortung aber im
jahr 2007 und ich glaube das ist ein
sehr gut nachvollziehbar gedanke wurden
wurde zwar der liefer gegenstand
reduziert von 1815 stück und auch eine
bestimmte qualität neu festgelegt aber
keineswegs rechtshandlungen die davor
passiert sind und vor allem
täuschungshandlungen arglistiger natur
betrügerischer natur abbildungen oder in
irgendeiner weise vereinbart also
insofern glaube ich ist die antwort hier
sehr eindeutig um zugunsten der republik
und der damaligen politisch
verantwortlichen danke jetzt bitte noch
drei fragen daher bitte hier
simon rosenau wiener zeitung eine frage
einen herrn p schauen sie haben gesagt
dass diese einkommen 1 milliarden
berührend wie juristischer mit materie
ich glaube es ihm gesagt noch nicht
endgültig entschieden ist was macht das
so speziell die frage ist schlicht um
die frage ist schlicht und ergreifend in
welchem umfang man sich einen betrag für
die verwendung des fluggerätes ab der
lieferung bis zum heutigen tag anrechnen
lassen muss
danke
bitte hier die dame vorletzte frage
christi knolle von reuters denke ich
muss auch wegen der 1,1 milliarden noch
mal nachfragen hier ist das überhaupt
nicht klar worauf klagen sie denn jetzt
oder lassen sie dass die
staatsanwaltschaft festlegen was ihnen
zusteht
ich verstehe das nicht dann wollte ich
fragen herr doch sie haben gesagt sie
sind bereit mit airbus zu sprechen heißt
das kann ich das auch so verstehen dass
sie nicht ausschließen
neue eurofighter zu kaufen und ich würde
auch noch mal interessieren haben waren
sie mit denen unternehmen während ihrer
untersuchungen in kontakt und worauf
genau begründen sie die aussage
airbus war nicht willens und das zu
liefern was sie uns versprochen haben
dass mir auch nicht klar
danke vielleicht zum zum ersten teil ich
bin bereit über die causa zu sprechen
bereit über die die inhalte und über die
folgen des privatbeteiligten anschlusses
zu sprechen
ich sage aber ganz klar dass er deutlich
der klargelegt und dargelegt dass wir
bis zum dreißigsten sechster
diese aufgabe wie zukünftig oder die
systeme zukünftig die
luftraumüberwachung tatsächlich in
österreich passiert in die experten
hände legen
die faktoren die voraussetzungen noch
einmal sind klar
militärisch effizient und wirtschaftlich
und unter diesen rahmenbedingungen wird
eine entscheidung getroffen
am 30 06 vielleicht der präsident bis zu
ihrem beiden fragen erstens ganz kurz
nach unserer schaden setzt sich zusammen
aus einer bereits eingetretenen schadens
teil
bis 31 12 216 und einem zukünftig
eintreten jetzt fokussiere ich mich auf
den bereits eingetretenen hier haben wir
den betrag von 1 1 milliarden nicht nur
genannt sondern detailliert so wie ich
es dargestellt habe
auch im privat beteiligten anschluss
ausgeführt den fordern wir auch und wir
fordern nicht nur die
sondern sollte sich in zukunft ein
weiterer schaden herausstellen was sehr
wahrscheinlich ist dann haben wir den
auch nicht nur jetzt schon bekannt
gegeben und mit einer feststellung
begehrt abgesichert sondern wir werden
diesen auch dann tatsächlich versuchen
durchzusetzen
das ist der eine teil und was war ihr
zweiter fall
danke das ergibt sich auch aus dem
normalen lebensumständen zusammenhang
mit den dokumenten die wir auf gefunden
haben und einem einfachen rechnung
diese aufrüstung hätte für airbus
wirtschaftliches desaster
schlicht und ergreifend bedeutet weil
sie mit kosten verbunden gewesen wäre
die fast in höhe des von airbus bei der
republik österreich blockierten
kaufpreises bestanden hätten
ich glaube man kann einem
börsennotierten unternehmen und dessen
unternehmen schlechthin im konzern
eine solche unvernünftige aus
wirtschaftlichen gesichtspunkten
vernünftige vorgangsweise nicht
unterstellen das haben wir getan
nun wird weiter
scheint so ja so wenn es keine fragen
mehr gibt eine letzte frage nach bitte
kind weil der kleine zeitung am herr
minister es eben gesagt bei der
luftraumüberwachung es künftig alles
möglich wenn ich wieder richtig zitiert
wer die frage um eine
luftraumüberwachung ohne eurofighter in
zukunft durchzuführen muss thema da bis
30.6 aus den verträgen herauskommen oder
und wenn ja wie wahrscheinlich ist es
dass man da bis 30.6 käme ich habe
ehrlich gesagt waren die verträge
beendet werden wo möglicherweise beendet
werden weil es eine andere situation
gibt sondern ich habe ganz klar gesagt
dass die beurteilung welchen weg wir
einschlagen
bis 30 06 liegen muss ergebnisoffen und
die schlägen muss noch einmal unter den
beiden parametern auch permanent hin
künftig eine effiziente militärische
luftraumüberwachung zu haben einerseits
aber andererseits und das ist genauso
wichtig wirtschaftlich und
kostengünstiger wie zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt dann danke fürs kommen und
dann schließe ich hiermit die
pressekonferenz